la primera ministra de finlandia sana
marín enfrenta a una nueva polémica tras
difundirse en redes sociales una foto de
dos de sus amigas en la residencia
oficial de los jefes de gobierno
finlandés las dos mujeres aparecen
besándose con el torso casi desnudo con
un letrero donde se lee finlandia la
mandataria admitió que la imagen está
tomada en la que sadam está y que en
efecto si son sus amigas aunque pidió
perdón por la imagen aseguro que no es
apropiada ella también dijo que se trató
de la única vez que se ha invitado a sus
amigos a la que se harán está durante
sus vacaciones y dejó claro que no
supuso ningún tipo de amenaza para la
seguridad del país esta nueva polémica
llega después de que la mandataria de 36
años fuera objeto de críticas tras la
publicación de un vídeo privado que ella
estaba cantando y bailando con sus
amigos marín aceptó incluso someterse a
una prueba de drogas que salió negativa
saludamos entonces a nuestra segunda
invitada al día ya patricia centeno
periodista analista y asesora en
estética y política corporativa
gracias.patricia por estar con nosotros
en directo américa 24 además experta en
comunicación política y verbal porque
está siendo tan atacada la primera
ministra finlandesa
bueno hola primero y creo que por varios
motivos
de hecho tristemente se le ataca por ser
mujer por ser joven por ser progresista
y por intentar estar haciendo otro tipo
de liderazgo no cuando se innova en mi
liderazgo no estamos acostumbrados y
todo eso como que nos perturba y nos
sorprende dicho esto es cierto que la
imagen privada de un representante
público
hay una línea muy fina entre lo que es
la imagen pública y la imagen privada y
por lo tanto esto siempre puede acarrear
problemas que debían haber estado
previstos tanto por la primera ministra
como por su equipo de comunicación y
aquí empiezan los principales problemas
que han habido al abordar este tipo de
crisis primero no ha habido previsión de
lo que podría acabar siendo una crisis
no porque tuviera una conducta
inapropiada que de hecho bailar no es
ningún delito pero sí que es este tipo
de imagen en manos de adversarios
políticos pues podían darle la vuelta a
esa información
descontextualizarla y por lo tanto
provocarle un problema y después pues
como hemos visto no la gestión de esta
crisis es durante lo que ha sido esta
semana además añadiendo nuevas
informaciones sobre el tiempo de ocio de
la primera ministra no ha ayudado porque
ella al final acabó como culpabilizando
ser o dando una imagen de culpa
cuando el hecho de una mujer de 36 años
que se divierte con sus amigos no es
necesario que esté drogada por lo tanto
en el primer momento todo aceptar ese
test antidrogas creo que ya fue un error
tanto por parte de la primera ministra
como el equipo de comunicación y de
imagen que la asesora claro patricia y
digamos que ella estaba segura de que
por supuesto no había consumido
estupefacientes para para estar pues
obviamente accediendo a este test y
además que no estaba haciendo
absolutamente nada malo también es
porque digamos que nos humaniza a los
políticos a nuestros líderes son
personas normales y corrientes que
también pues tienen derecho a divertirse
con sus amigos a salirse un poco de las
funciones pero sin dejar un lado
perfectamente la responsabilidad que
tiene como como líder de un país pero
porque digamos en ese en este caso
específico del test antidrogas fue algo
negativo porque pues muchos pensarían
que bueno calmar yo un poco la sociedad
y las críticas diciendo que pues que
ella no estaba consumiendo ningún tipo
de estupefacientes
el problema es que este tipo de pruebas
no se le ha exigido antes a un
mandatario es decir hemos visto a otros
mandatarios en situaciones ya no
similares ella no hablo de un baile
pensar o llegar a la conclusión de que
una persona que se está divirtiendo se
lo está pasando bien necesita o es
obligatorio que haya consumido algún
tipo de droga aunque sea alcohol lo que
más
hemos tolerado todo si es más permisivo
es algo es un anunciado equipo
equivocado no entonces cuando hay otro
tipo de decisiones porque hemos visto a
muchos hombres líderes tomar decisiones
como puede ser conquistar o invadir un
país o entrar en una guerra a nadie se
le ha ocurrido pedirle un test
antidrogas a esa persona o se le ha
pedido un test psiquiátrico no y son
tomas de decisiones que sí que nos
afectan directamente el hecho de que una
primera ministra de 36 años quede con
sus amigos y haga una fiesta es
responsabilidad suya es cierto que las
imágenes desde la residencia oficial de
la jefa del gobierno eso seguramente
debía tener un control también las
imágenes que están tomando en una
discoteca también debían haber estado
bueno debía haber guardado
este tipo de imagen pero más allá de ahí
ha habido una equivocación pero no se ha
dado un delito en cambio cuando vemos y
hemos visto y hemos sido partícipes de
otros vi líderes mundiales que han
tomado decisiones que nos afectan mucho
más que son mucho más difíciles de
entender y nadie jamás le ha exigido
algo así entonces que ella aceptará este
test antidrogas creo que es como
reconocer que las mujeres tenemos que
seguir justificando nos por cada una de
las acciones que tomamos claro y eso
precisamente era el paso a lo que le
quería preguntar no a continuación y es
que si esto le hubiera pasado a un
hombre pues es simplemente pide perdón
no pasó nada y todo el mundo sigue como
sí pues de nada hubiera pasado realmente
no pasó nada no pasa una grave pero pues
evidentemente en las sociedades
machistas en la mayoría y vivimos pues
una mujer y más siendo joven es atacada
por este tipo de conductas perfectamente
normales en cualquier ser humano
y de hecho en 2019 un caso algo parecido
alexandre o acaso cortez que es una
congresista muy bien joven de los eeuu
muy conocido y muy popular en el resto
del mundo también por parte de los
republicanos también intentaron
ridiculizar la no
mostrarnos cómo transmitirnos la idea de
que una mujer joven bailando porque
habían rescatado un vídeo de su etapa
universitaria en la que ella bailaba y
cantaba es una persona que se divierte
está incapacitada para después liderar o
representar a andar al pueblo que hizo
el ya le dio la vuelta es decir lo que
consiguió es ridiculizar a aquellas
personas que piensan que por el hecho de
que un político se divierta eso es algo
negativo entonces ella misma se grabó un
vídeo en el congreso diciéndoles bueno
pues si les ha vuelto locos que una
mujer no se le está escandalizado que
una mujer baile imaginen qué va a pasar
cuando vean que esta congresista está
bailando y en ese momento se puso a
bailar entonces naturalizar siempre es
neutralizar una crisis y de hecho hemos
visto otras crisis de imagen en las que
sí que había una conducta inapropiada e
incluso
que en la que se cometía un delito y
hemos visto cómo los líderes hombres
simplemente pedían como bien decías
perdón o simplemente pasaban por encima
de esa crisis y en este caso yo creo que
el error de comunicación de la primera
ministra de finlandia ha sido
culpabilizarse caer en la trampa que le
habían entendido sus sus adversarios